all right i i think we're live so uh
hello everyone and welcome to the
christmas cake defy arena uh we're we're
currently all right i i think we're live
so hello mute to this so we don't have
echo uh currently we have uh over
fourteen thousand people so fourteen
thousand three hundred and sixty seven
seventy one uh you know people are still
joining and okay so it's the stream
seems to be working as people are saying
hi in the chat for those of you who
still haven't joined uh the tournament
link is in the description below uh okay
i can even just test it if it works and
it works yeah so you guys can use it
and um uh yeah this is gonna be uh this
is gonna be a pretty wild event uh i did
not expect such uh such a such a big
event but it seems that everyone
is very interested uh in uh you know
showing who's best but not only that
also in the in the price fund
it would seem
uh so we have these are the top 10
currently uh so the the uh the top 10 in
the tournament are rated over um
rated over 3 000 and even magnus carlsen
just joined uh i think he he joined like
this second uh so yeah now he's
currently uh rated number three on the
list uh behind the narrow disc here and
uh kona vlad that's uh uh vladislav
uh so we'll see
this is gonna be pretty crazy so i think
we have pretty much everyone here uh
this is basically the this is basically
the world bullet championship
uh you guys are saying that quality is
bad uh
uh
shouldn't be but uh
usually when the quality is bad it says
uh all right it's uh
uh something something wrong with the
with the stream but it there shouldn't
be like um a pretty bad quality
uh which one is dania naruditsuki is uh
rebecca harris uh in um currently seed
number two you can see their grandmaster
uh rebecca harris and all all in the top
10 are grand masters only in number
eight you have from vietnam uh
uh mutt pro or i don't know how to
pronounce that that's mean lay
international master
yeah
as someone says you probably have your
quality on auto and then it just drops
144 p but if you set it up to 720p or
full hd the quality should be fine
maybe i should do some videos from this
tournament uh yeah i mean i would i
would love to uh probably there will be
some really amazing games because it's
not a one minute tournament it's it's
two minutes and for these monsters
that's plenty
and if you guys manage to check out uh
some of the games aside from the
ones that will be streamed do share in
the comment section or you know send me
an email uh because it's impossible to
check all of these games and uh the okay
the tournament starts in 15 minutes uh
deletious team informed me that uh okay
we had that one uh incident where the
server crashed um
i think in the not in the previous
tournament but in the one before that uh
and um
well it shouldn't be the case in this
one but just in case it happens uh the
tournament will be restarted uh so
everything should work fine but if it
doesn't crash in the first minute uh
then we're then we're good to go
uh so yeah so here you can see the top
seed for the moment is vladislav then we
have uh rebecca harris that's
naruditsuki then a doctor championstein
that's magnus carlsen the world champion
then we have penguin
with his
second or third account uh as you can
see cloud9 cloud9 cloud9 clan i also
that's andrew tang for those of you who
don't don't know then in fifth place
nine king that's um alexander boternick
also grand master from the united states
alireza uh as the sixth seed
is also playing sergey giugalko a bullet
expert here on leeches
a vietnam vietnam international master i
mean in eighth then we have watneg i
don't know who whatnig is uh seems like
a very strong player probably maybe i
mean probably some of you know so if you
do know do share and i'm gonna
uh share it with um everyone else but uh
not sure who it is just today also uh
not sure uh but as you can see the the
first like 60 uh players like the first
six pages are all grandmasters pretty
much so azara 25 this may or may not be
a niche geary someone uh did mention
this but i cannot confirm uh tsm ftxh
that's hikaru nakamura uh playing with
his newly created leeches account uh uh
or or so it would seem
uh then we have vladimir which uh that's
uh andreikin uh very strong russian
grandmaster svod mevco this is daniel
dubov uh
so you know it pretty much everyone is
playing there there are so many players
here it's hard to even imagine look at
this sesipinko uh so many so many gm's
gm gm gm gm taking space he and that's
jordan he won uh uh the last tournament
that i held or maybe he won the the
second place yeah the first place was
won by a mystery person uh a senior i
believe
and uh yeah thank you i think for the
contribution uh cal rep
i'm very glad to be streaming this but
i'm pretty sure everyone is streaming
this so you guys are uh you guys are
spoiled for choice as are we spoiled for
choice uh for you know in choosing
which games to check out so i'm just
gonna randomly uh you know check out the
games of course we're gonna mostly
follow the games from the leaders but uh
yeah we'll see how it goes
so yeah pretty much uh once again uh
once again uh hello everyone to everyone
and uh yeah uh uh i will be i will be tr
i will try to
uh read the chat as much as possible but
we will also be checking out the game so
if anyone has anything really important
to ask or say we still have 20 minutes
uh 12 minutes until the beginning of the
tournament
i yeah thank you mr sean carter yes this
is already a success it is uh far beyond
anything i imagined so
uh really really nicely done uh
yeah
uh people people respond uh really well
to to large price funds it would seem so
thanks again to the cake defy also for
uh sponsoring the event
yeah maggie is playing uh marco
conscious
who are those gm's uh yeah those are
pretty much all the all the gm's are
playing yeah i think yeah all of them
are playing this is uh
yeah this is uh without uh
uh you know without overselling it that
this is the world bullet championship if
you consider two plus old bullet uh the
reason why i didn't make it a oneplus
saw is that um
some people
don't prefer watching bullet whereas two
plus o is almost three plus so which is
blitz and then it's you know uh more
digestible uh so i i thought maybe two
two plus o will make it um
more enjoyable for everyone even though
yes it's possible to cheat it's always
possible to cheat and it's i guess a
little bit easier to cheat and two plus
so than it is in one plus so
but it's something that we're gonna have
to you know deal with we can only
organize the tournament invite the
players and
try and make it happen uh but it will
always be
uh you know uh upon the cheaters to
cheat and well uh
i i think the the the system is set up
so
it's it's not very likely that they will
succeed they will they will maybe
succeed one or two games uh but then
their accounts will be banned
uh i should have uh
uh
not allowed berserking no i'm a big fan
of berserking and that's exactly
also one of the reasons why i made it a
two plus or another one plus oh so you
can berserk and make it one plus so uh
which is uh
i think it's very very important to
berserk in order to win this uh because
there are so many players and i think
the situation at the top will be so so
crazy i i don't know
like okay now that magnus is playing
anything is possible but you have magnus
alireza and hikaru in the same bullet
tournament i i don't know if that ever
happened oh it i mean it must have
happened at some point but uh
yeah i really don't uh
don't think it did
maybe it did i don't know
kryptonite you are sacrificing your
sleep that's uh that's
nice to know
hey kaushik charlie hey man
what is berserking ah berserking is uh
berserking is when you sacrifice half of
your time at the start of the game so
you don't have two minutes you have one
minute but you get more points when you
actually win the game so it's much
harder to win but you are rewarded uh
for that
yeah that bitcoin definitely bringing
out the muscle
can i name all those gm's please no i
can't because uh i don't know all of
them like i know most of them but um
not not all of them
yeah we have uh all right and we have
another gentleman joining uh
uh here at at the top ten i don't know
who it is spicy caterpillar
so it's a it's a mystery person oh it's
ray robson ray robson so he is not a
mystery person so uh thank you for for
joining
uh yes
i've read gotham is also uh playing uh
or rather he he is registered on leeches
now but i don't know if he will be
playing
i've seen that um
he did play at least 50 games that is
required to join okay i know i could
have made it like 200 games you have to
play at least 200 games in order to join
the tournament that would maybe but i
like i could make it a thousand games
and you know if someone wanted to cheat
they would play the thousand bullet
games i mean it's not uh
it's not impossible to imagine that
yeah 15 000 people so far registered for
the tournament seven minutes to go if
any of you guys who are watching want to
join in the link is in the description
below so you are welcome to
uh welcome to join in and make the event
even greater
uh
you know it's it's uh
it's just a great event i'm just so
uh so so impressed by uh how many people
uh are playing that i i would just be
happy
by just watching it
which one is hikaru hikaru is currently
seed number 11 no now he's now he's seed
number 13 uh tsm ftxh or or so i've so
i've heard
you you are a seed 8000 that's pretty
good in this uh in this field the seed
8000 is uh
is very very good
yeah the time format is two plus so so
two minutes plus zero seconds increment
uh what's carlson's nickname carlson's
nickname is dr championstein here uh
currently seated number three uh i think
he only used the account
to play one event uh you know the one
where they were
having some beers and enjoying
themselves yeah he played a total of 64
games so far so uh but by playing that
event he basically registered this
account for this tournament
yeah we'll see
cornevlad is artemiev
yeah so i i think we have we have uh
like uh so so many so many top players
here it's uh
it's simply amazing
will i show magnus versus hikaru in a
video on the channel i i most certainly
will if uh if they clash at some point
and the chances are they will
uh yeah
i mean uh
uh i'm i'm probably gonna be covering
games from this tournament for the
entire uh 2022
so
we'll see
alyu marafa thank you man thank you for
the for the nice comments
oh yes i have uh i have congratulated
levy on his on his marriage yes that is
there is very joyous news
yeah we're gonna we're gonna check out
uh one game at a time and uh when
choosing the next game that we're gonna
uh check out uh i'm i'm mostly choosing
the ones that are just starting uh but
uh you know if if if magnus has a pretty
crazy position or something like that we
will mostly likely uh choose that one
am i happy with the lineup yes i'm very
happy with the lineup uh it's uh
it's the it's the it's the dream lineup
it's uh yeah it's it's the it's the
world bullet championship basically
yeah for as i see
a lot of people are still asking in the
chat rebecca harris is daniel naraditsky
the left side of the rankings is cut off
oh
yeah that's true
shouldn't be but it is i don't know why
i could maybe improve on it a little bit
just give me a second
yeah it does appear to be
cut off a little bit there you go maybe
this will help
all right at least now you will see the
okay i think it fixed it we'll see now i
know there's a couple of seconds delay
in the stream all right there we go
obs adjusted
is any martich playing yeah uh
i'm kinda
i'm thinking they are
but it's uh hard to say uh
yeah chronoldino is playing
uh
nope his son is not playing
and the other sun is not playing so only
cronullino is playing uh and usado maybe
nopiozarov is not playing so only
cronullino so we'll see
who is the wet neck uh maybe i've
mentioned but uh i don't know i think
it's a mystery person yeah whatneg is a
mystery person
if some of you know do do share
definitely share
yeah yeah c9 c9 it's andrew tang
yeah it could be uh no it's not nihal
it's not nihal uh
nihal has uh has his own um uh handle on
on unleashes a verified so i don't think
it's this one but uh it seems you can it
seems you can have uh as many as you
want so it is possible
aditya thank you thank you for the
contribution man
yes dubo is here dubois is here dubo is
currently seated uh
where is he seated at number 15 he is a
grand master sword mevco
why didn't i visit dubai uh well i have
a little baby at home uh so i can't you
know just leave for a couple of days uh
while she's so very very little
uh but for for the next world
championship i'm i'm definitely
definitely coming is whatneck
yeah it could be could be
yeah giri is also support supposedly
playing uh as azara 25 so uh i i don't
have that confirmed like it's just uh
something someone told me
do i need a babysitter no no that that's
uh
that's why i i didn't go to
to dubai so we don't have to have a
babysitter
who is night king
yeah i i'm pretty sure he is a game of
thrones fan uh that's uh alexander
boternick uh grandmaster
uh yeah i'm pretty sure nepo is only
chess i just don't know his handle
but i'm pretty sure
he is
now that uh
now that uh
hikaru joined alicia's also i think
pretty much everyone is now unleashes
am i covering any games on youtube yeah
i i certainly hope i am uh
i mean there are so many
uh people people keep saying that
geppetto is nepo actually so uh as so
many people said it already
uh
i know i've seen it somewhere ah here in
uh yeah c22
geppetto is nepo but
here it says from italy
so unless nepo is trolling us i don't
think that would that would be him
no no that's not nippo
will i will i cover the world rapid and
blitz yes i will ah the server crash
yeah they said if the server doesn't
crash in the first one minute that it
shouldn't be
ah
all right
nope there is no player registered as
geppetto
uh yeah i've seen i've seen armenian
players uh in the
uh in in the registered players area
no i don't know who lima is
when are you gonna see my daughter well
i guess as soon as she can at least sit
on her own i can you know put her behind
with with meadow to enjoy the games
we'll see we'll see if she likes chess
maybe she doesn't
alright so uh i think the tournament
just started let me just check
okay let's refresh this page
uh all right nothing is happening yet
so
we'll see if the if the server crashed
or
let me just check
perhaps uh
it it is possible that it crashed
we'll see but uh i'm uh i'm in uh
contact with the
with the leeches team so
if it crashed they will inform me and uh
we will get
a new link
to the tournament
let's see
nope it seems that it crashed
or maybe it didn't
nope i'm i'm getting messages that it
definitely crashed for everyone so okay
so we've uh
we've obviously made chess very very
popular today so everyone wanted to join
and play uh let me just check
let me just check what are the good
people at leaches
doing
yeah they will they will get back at me
no worries
yeah spamming in the chat does not help
here on delicious chat i'm sure that
only
uh
it increases the problem
yeah no games is starting yeah their
server crashed
okay they say one moment uh they are
figuring it out and will get back to me
soon
all right so yeah 17 000 people that's a
lot that's a lot
all right so well what do you what do
you expect i mean it's uh it's a pretty
pretty uh dramatic start to the
tournament uh
so
uh we're gonna have a good one i'm sure
they'll get it up up and running it's
not uh
that's not even
a
question but uh it will probably take
them a few minutes
yeah but the the site is or is it
yeah the
no i think the site
ah the entire site crashed oh
or
because the chat is working i just can't
refresh the site
yeah alireza 2003 is firuja
2003 is firuja
yeah they have to feed the the little
hamsters that uh drive the servers
yeah i chose two plus so because it's
it's not one plus so so too fast for
everyone but it's not uh you know three
plus oh and uh that's a little bit slow
usado's chess channel says i can't get
in yes it's out of this because uh well
the the deletious servers are
working it out currently
so i don't know if we'll be able to use
the same link but as soon as they make a
new one which
is probably the most likely case i will
just put the link in the description
below and also
share it on twitter so pretty pretty
sure okay
there we go
there we go very nicely done
let me just uh
check here if
[Music]
everything is operational
there we go
okay
[Music]
yeah still figuring it out
all right leeches org is officially down
there we go
very nicely done
we expected to be back very soon thank
you for your patience
all right i'd i'd expect no less
all right so so what have you guys been
up to
and alexander graf welcome to welcome to
the team welcome to excellent
subscribers
yeah no the the tournament will will
resume at some point i just hope that
someone didn't plan like the exact time
two hours and that's it because now it
might be might be two and a two and a
something hours
all right let me just check if uh if
someone is
saying anything to me
nope
nope people are just nicely tweeting
about how how
uh how the site crashed very nicely done
yes that's very nice all right we got
the site back
and the tournament is back
uh
let me just check if
oh
no the players obviously were playing
it's just that we couldn't see no
no leeches is down ah yeah because uh
when the when it goes down it doesn't go
for everyone at the same time it goes
down for i think some of them and then
some of them continue playing so that's
why you were seeing some uh some players
already had some points
why is my name agatha matar that is uh
that is a great secret
[Laughter]
nice nice nice nice
all right
uh i have some info from the from
religious team they say they are still
working so no worries
yeah i know i told you the meeting a few
months ago but
not everyone saw the video obviously
yeah we crashed leeches and there is
nothing more to be done here
yeah okay i mean it's not like uh this
is uh so uh so many players because
there were tournaments uh like in the
previous tournament that i organized
there were five and a half thousand
people and i think leeches already had
one tournament with like 8 000 or maybe
even 10 000 it was a marathon you know
the tournament that lasted for like a
week
so i mean 15 000 is not that far off
they should have prepared for the event
i'm sure they did prepare for the event
but uh as you know the the little
hamsters are
the little hamsters that run the servers
are tricky bastards
alright site can be reached no worries
it will it will come
yeah carlson joins server leaves
what's the dog's name uh the dog's name
is meadow
and he is very old i often say that he
is he's pretty ancient
dale blackman thanks for the
contribution man
they prepared for the event but so did
nepo and we know how he ended up yeah
yeah preparation isn't everything
there's also the the middle game
yes of course the the points will reset
it's uh of course the tournament will
not resume unfairly
yeah the ancient dogo has been around
since chess began he is uh
he is the the
grand all father of chess
[Music]
thanks for the contribution man
why is your wife looking at you in
disbelief because the the the sight
broke
all right i'm i'm getting informed by
the leech esteem that a new tournament
is being made so everyone will just be
i don't know if everyone will
automatically be shifted to the new one
they will probably have to rejoin uh so
probably not uh
not all 17 000 people will join
as i'm pretty sure someone just joined
because they want to be a part of of
something not to actually play so maybe
we'll see like fifteen thousand
yes meadow the oracle
all right it's a cast at the bar in the
library yes everyone was uh yeah i know
you guys ordered some cold beers and you
know maybe some some food and you know
you were expecting some nice clash
between magnus and alireza and then the
site crashes yeah i know that's very
very disturbing but we will get it back
no worries
you should probably have another beer
while you're waiting
yeah fifteen thousand joining at the
same time won't crack the site again
yeah i i don't think it will
maybe they're they're probably uh
reallocating the the resources so maybe
they will now you know
put all the power in this tournament i
don't know how how it goes
[Music]
all right so something is happening
something is loading
how big of a bar and library would we
need to fill 18 000 players
i don't know i'm sure dubai could make
one
they can make anything
yes of course
of course the the website will be
restarted all right so here the the site
is back
maybe only temporarily no it's back and
the
the tournament is going on but of course
it will be restarted i i see people are
playing it but uh
yeah it will be restarted
yeah it's interesting so some people
managed to play while others haven't
yeah it's really weird how that happens
but no worries yeah yeah it's gonna be
back
yeah currently there are 18 000 players
but uh
so i'm expecting to receive
i'm expecting to receive a new link at
some point
right
let me just check
yeah still nothing
carl dieder thanks for the contribution
man you ate all your snacks already
yeah of course if you guys were in the
tournament then you won the first game
because the opponent didn't move because
it didn't um the the tournament didn't
stop for all players only only some of
them it would seem but no the tournament
will get restarted that's uh
without question
so as soon as uh as soon as the good
people of leeches inform me we're gonna
shift to that one
yeah they have to restart of course
mark hermann thanks thanks for joining
man welcome to the welcome to the
excellent subscribers team
yeah they of course they didn't start at
the same time
yeah don't uh don't don't worry about
this one don't don't even try to get
back in this tournament because a new
one will be created yeah okay so this
one is over
so in the fake tournament uh where the
server crashed the winners are tcon09 uh
cuba 87 and the dimitri uh anikunov so
congratulations guys but this is not the
the actual tournament
all right so i'm expecting a new link
uh and then i will
put it uh put it back in the uh well in
the description below so you guys can
can be shifted to that
all right
let me just check if i received anything
nope not yet there i'm now making a new
one
all right
there we go
yeah congrats to decon for winning that
was uh i think that was the the quickest
win ever for for such a great event
he he crushed everyone
james craig thanks for the contribution
man and no there is not a rating limit
for this tournament you can be rated as
as high as you want or as low as you
want so no rating cap
i don't know i don't know if your elo
will uh be refunded but i'm sure that's
somewhere in the description of the
tournament like in the case of a side
crash your your rating will not be
refunded
yeah it will be restarted no worries
they are they are still making a new
tournament
let me just check real quickly
okay
yeah second tournament to bitcoin yeah
how do you stop cheating well you you
try really hard and you stop
but if you meant how do you stop
cheating in a tournament uh i'm sure
they have some
very uh very sophisticated software that
does that probably lira alila with her
uh you know
all-seeing guy watches all the games and
then we you know eliminate all the
cheaters
thanks for the contribution man you are
on your fourth beer yeah okay uh i'm
sure you could you could squeeze in a
few more
it's only two hour uh for for the
tournament so another four should be
should be just uh you know just right to
hit the spot
uh okay we still don't have the link for
the new tournament but uh they will
probably set up everything the same as
in this one and then they will set it up
to start maybe in some five minutes or
maybe 10 minutes
enough for for everyone to join
black won 79 percent of the games yeah
okay so it would seem that only white
players
got eliminated
no i i don't smash eight beers all long
gone are the days when i could smash
eight beers now now two is my limit
as uh i you guys know i've had the heart
surgery and the the my surgeon told me
no no crossing the two beer limit he
said only if it's a really really good
party you can you know maybe do four but
if it's like a casual event you know
don't don't go over two
yeah only white players get eliminated
yeah no youtube's algorithm is gonna
come for me again
ah
nipple tweeted what what did he tweet
aha yeah okay
let me just check
yeah nipple says dear leeches i did
everything i could sit down at the
computer poured some tea
and then you know sad face and the
crying smiley everything crashed
what are you gonna do
yeah the
uh but it's funny because uh
some three hours ago i i tweeted that oh
okay nice we already have over ten
thousand players i hope the servers will
hold and then they didn't
yeah but now now i guess we know what
nepo was drinking during the wheelchair
championship match as he now tweeted
that he already poured some tea
and we were discussing whether the
uh
the beverage at his uh table was tea or
coffee so now i guess we know it was t
all right so i've received a new link
let me just grab that
the new link is somewhere here all right
let me just take that
there we go okay so the new tournament
is starting
in
three minutes
there we go all right i'm updating it
now
there we go
all right tournament link updated
all right damn
okay just a second
all right the tournament link should be
updated now there we go
all right and the arena starts in two
minutes
all right leeches uh
okay they tweeted that the new one is
starting so let me just retweet that so
more people can see
and we'll see all right so now as you
can see we have 5 000 players and people
are
joining very rapidly so let me just
tweet the link again
[Music]
there we go
all right
so hopefully that will help and let me
know if the one uh in the description
below works i did
i did change it so should be should be
working
yeah
three minutes is enough because everyone
is at their computer and ready to play
it's uh it's how these things work you
know
all right and you can see that the
number of players is growing rapidly
already at seven thousand four hundred
seven five hundred
marty alexandra thank you for the
contribution yeah a dead matter
all right so
now we have magnus as top seed
uh
oh now magnus is uh top seed okay so it
seems that magnus played some games
while
everyone was just chilling so he would
be the top seed in the tournament very
very nicely done magnus
no no dr championstein is magnus here
you can see that's magnus carnevale
that's uh artemia then you have
narudicki
and so on we've covered all of them uh
all right eight thousand fifty okay it's
growing rapidly there we go
ah you think artemis lost his elo from
the last one i could also could also be
possible yeah could also be possible
dropped points during the crash
and that's why
magnus is now the top seed all right
so it seems that it will start now
all right so starting in 20 seconds and
uh all right the site is
connecting reconnecting connecting
reconnecting so hopefully it will be
operational now over 9000 it's over 9000
players
alright so hopefully that's it the
tournament starts and it started alright
let's check out all right
let's go
first game magnus versus artemiev
uh
let's see let's let's do this so we have
a nice sicilian
with a c3 okay so this is this is going
to be a nice bullet line
with some bishop maneuvering i imagine
but no no this is ah this is okay this
is very nice
all right so there we have it it seems
that everything is working but it's
still not uh completely set uh because
uh if it
it has to hold for at least one minute
before
uh before we're sure that it's gonna
hold
all right so they're they're pretty much
equal in time this is the first game
they're playing in the tournament uh let
me know if you guys hear the double
moves because i also have the the volume
up so i can hear the moves but if it's
too loud for you i can lower the sound
of the second
of the of the second move
sound
what's meadows leeches rating uh they
they don't want to give him a rating i
i'm discussing with leeches to give
meadow a rating but
so far we haven't come to an agreement
con vlad is vladislav
really
it's it's too loud
all right so magnus playing much much
faster so he still has e he's playing
like he's playing bullet
uh but i don't think that will be
the the biggest problem for for tamiya
meadow at least 26.50 yeah i would say
so i would say so
all right he wants okay not a queen
trade but he just wants to get uh
his pieces into the game and he's doing
so much better on time that i don't
think he needs to be worried
nice centralizing move with the queen
there we go now a bishop against knight
let's see how he how magnus plays this
yeah
okay he wants to create a pass pawn very
nice
okay he doesn't want to trade
yeah there's
too big of a time difference
i'm making out that matter is worth the
money
uh i think andrew joined yeah
okay so uh we have a queen trade
material still equal it's a a night
against bishop with uh the scary past c
pawn from agnes oh nice nice he can't
capture the pawn ah that's it
very nicely done by magnus all right so
let's check it out
uh all right so
a person who may or may not be hikaru
against uh
the board theme look bad uh that's the
standard leeches uh board theme that i
use i think it's the nicest one
uh so sorry if if if you don't agree
agree with it
yeah what a move for a bullet yeah
magnus played it instantly but that's
because uh it's uh it's a well-known
idea of course that magnus knows and
then it's not uh
not a problem for him yeah okay since
everyone is saying it's 100 hikaru and
hikaru also confirmed it yeah then it is
definitely hikaru
because i know okay people have been
saying for for a while now that it's
hikaru but then they said that maybe it
isn't so
all right and uh hikaru berserk did this
so it's a very very interesting game and
white is holding his own definitely
he's up a pawn
which is very impressive to say the
least
okay why did white is playing incredibly
incredibly precise moves
but hikaru is faster yeah even though he
berserked him hikaru is
he he's down
almost twice on time but uh
what's this
white resigned black is victorious
all right oh probably
probably white uh
yeah white uh was an engine user and the
behind the leeches website figured him
out so they
gave the points to hikaru
alright so one one one cheater down and
hikaru gets the win all right so we have
a little peasant against the ogrila two
grand masters
tell the players to play the evans
gambit
yeah i mean okay it was uh of course i'm
not gonna say anything but it's a 1700
player who plays
such incredible chess against hikaru in
bullet
it was a little bit odd it's not
impossible but of course we're not gonna
you know just point fingers
yeah but it was a nice try but as you
can see you will not be able to cheat in
this tournament and uh what's also nice
is that the
person who's getting cheated does not
lose any points or loses valuable time
in the tournament so you know the points
were awarded to him
yeah every time b4 is played take a shot
i do not have any shots here
unfortunately
and uh i'm currently on a no alcohol
regime until christmas
uh just you know for fun
so
otherwise i would have some shots but i
usually have shots when i have uh
someone to co-stream with
can i explain the rules of the
tournament
it's uh it's chess tournament
people play chess two minutes per player
you can also berserk which means you can
give up half your time and then you get
more points if you win and that's it
it's not um uh that you play uh you know
a fixed number of games it's an arena so
oh wow what a checkmate what a checkmate
and that is a that is a nasty double
bishop checkmate
that is that is just amazing
all right so getting back to it
uh
max oh this is i think this is max
farmer dumb yeah it is uh so let's check
out his game he's leading the tournament
currently
yeah it's oh those those were some fully
operational bishops
yeah
uh how do you i mean
you okay if if you just uh said everyone
who is playing good moves is cheating
then we'd be oh and that's a nice fork
uh you know it'd be a
no that's a very nice checkmate it would
be a sad world to live in so
you know
suspiciously incredibly precise moves
are being played that's how we that's
how we say it
all right so
a lot of people playing incredible chess
so far
uh let's check out who do we have all
right let's manier okay he just lost one
okay let me just check
okay
leeches team is informing me that that
it is definitely hikaru yeah
how can someone cheat with such fast
time i don't know i'm not an expert but
i'm pretty sure you have to use some
scripts or something
um
but um you know as they say where
there's a will there's a way
yeah that's the good stuff thanks for
the contribution ram
i was it was not a cheater it was max
deutsch in fact
yeah
yes we found out who dubo is uh but i
forgot i forgot the name
people won't like berserk it's sort of
unfair what's unfair about berserk
it's the only fair thing you you give up
some of your time to to gain points
all right
let me just pick one that's starting out
our kick do we have one that's starting
out
nope
okay this is a pretty crazy position so
i can't spend too much time trying to
figure out which game is starting out
because then we'll miss out on a lot
yeah yeah whiz i know you can middle
click but i'm not a middle click person
i prefer the right click left click
combo
ah magnus stopped playing yeah okay
i guess he was he was annoyed by the by
the
crash
what are you gonna do
a little peasant i'm pretty sure i know
who little peasant is uh it's ramirez
alejandro ramirez okay uh versus magnus
fischer he just won a very nice game
uh and he's currently leading the
tournament
uh let's see
all right this one's just starting out
video master uh
strelok222222 from russia no sure not
sure who it is but i lost four games to
him
as delete just says
how magnus is playing okay maybe he took
like uh
like a small break
so
yes for the sword mevco is do well i
can't from i you know can't seem to
remember that so the mevca all right but
i'm pretty sure i will remember it now
all right let's let's check it out
black black under a lot of pressure here
uh i don't think it's uh
very likely for him to hold it even
though he is much higher rated but we'll
see
surya trivedi thanks for the
contribution man
and and the best wishes yeah dr
champions time is magnus but uh he's
currently at 25 okay
little peasant is uh alejandro ramirez
hikaru jumped to three magnus date all
right thank you guys uh
for for informing me as uh i don't see
the standings while we're checking out
the game make sure to inform me at the
chat
at all times
yeah i thought about inviting a guest
but with the current situation you know
no one is really comfortable
joining uh joining as a guest
so maybe maybe we give it a bit more
time
yeah i'm not i'm not a multiple tab guy
i like to have my tabs neat
alireza's nickname is alireza 2003
something like that
why did you get banned mid-game you
didn't cheat uh it's hard to say
probably they either thought you were
cheating or something something else
okay
so
white is down material but it doesn't
seem to be a problem for him uh not not
i don't think black will be able to
to hold this but we'll see
yeah okay so as you guys are saying
anish is a zaro 25
yeah imagine cheating and acting like
you didn't that's that's far worse than
just cheating
what happened to again maturino uh i
don't think anything happened to him he
just uh
he's just staying offline for the moment
so
no no need to worry guys
and it's a repetition
very very interesting very interesting
all right so who is playing all right
let's see alireza is back let's check it
out alireza versus
and uh oh they've already played uh so
many games they've played 33 games so
far
alireza dropped some rating points but
it's probably due to the due to the
disconnect
all right uh white allowing this sneaky
queen captures an a2 but i've seen this
uh being allowed in in many lines so
we'll see if
all it is i can pull it off
he's doing a nice king walk oh king of
three wow that's uh that's
that's very nice
wow that's uh that's a real
that's a real nice square for the king
oh now h4 probably no he's not afraid
he's not h4 yeah he has to make some
room for the king
and now
wow this is this is such a
f
such a crazy oh h5
what is
h5 h5 obviously is nothing
oh i thought h5 was just uh some
brilliancy that uh you know was just
gonna destroy alireza but it doesn't
seem so
uh so alireza takes this one
all right
let's see who is hikaru playing
ah he's playing against max yeah that's
the game you guys were mentioning
alright so it's a
no queen for hikaru and queen
for for max
so let's see how hikaru does it uh
queenless
i were hoping magnus would secretly play
as johan solomon's account yeah that's
uh that's pretty pretty crazy video
yeah this already guy is pretty good
yeah
oh nicely done nicely done by hikaru
very nicely done
oh magnus joins the the top 10 and he
lost one game now
so tough for him but i didn't check uh
uh were people berserking or or are they
just enjoying their their games with
full time
maybe as
everyone is so strong uh they they just
don't berserk against one one another
but i i i'm not sure
no no it's it's not max deutsch it's not
max deutsch
akiko berserked a few okay
no i'm gonna check right after right
after we check out this game
so what is okay magnus has to defend
against mate and now the queens get
traded off and now magnus is down a
piece
so this will be very interesting
can magnus beat him down a piece
this will be
he will either resign or he will not he
will just
try try and win on time
okay so he's preventing knight c4 i
guess
yeah he he will probably have to start
push those uh those king side pawns but
maybe he will just try and keep a solid
position you know so nothing nothing can
go wrong
bishop d2 here maybe
hmm
okay he's better on time but still
this would be this would be amazing
all right so we'll check how this game
ended you guys say uh alireza is playing
hikaru so let's uh let's check it out
no there is not playing hikaru
you guys you guys uh you guys trolled me
so let's let's finish this game
i was a draw offered wow
so it was a pretty pretty quick one
yeah you baited yeah
and look at this look at this magnus
just uh entered the winning end game
with twice the time on the clock this is
uh yeah this is pretty crazy
yeah okay i i will try to show you guys
uh but uh you know usually if if we
start a game i i don't want to you know
rush close it
to see another one unless it's like uh
two rooks against uh no rooks and uh
it's uh it's a clear win okay so then
maybe we can check out another one but
unless uh that's the case
all right now
oh even that wow even that
of course
oh
nicely done so magnus wins this wins the
end game down a piece
incredible okay who is alireza playing
uh ramirez
all right so let's see
yeah i'm just gonna randomly pick games
uh and if it's uh
uh if it's uh anywhere near the
beginning of the game we're gonna check
it out
yeah it makes it look so easy i mean how
do you how do you do that
alireza berserking him so we'll see if
he can do it
yeah this is uh
i mean
when you berserk it's intense to play
but it's also intense to just watch i
mean
uh when when you berserk a grand master
that's
wow now c3 because the rook is hanging
on c4 very nice
very nicely done
oh even bishop yeah
it's just so fast like in a fraction of
a second
okay black defends solidly
already is upper bishop but he is
getting getting attacked
okay so now the hmm
yeah let's just enjoy this
okay so alireza doesn't uh think it's a
problem to go for the end game uh being
down so much on the clock oh he even
picks up the rook nice
nicely done
all right let's see what is playing next
okay let's let's check it out
against grandmaster sparta uh not sure
who it is if you guys if you guys know
do share
and they both berserked very nice
yeah yeah for those of you who
who still are not
familiar with berserking yes you get
more points if you berserk
[Music]
uh you you give up half your time and
you win more points if you if you win
yeah but it's also it's also very
unpleasant to play when your opponent
berserks and you don't because i in this
um time format it's hard to maybe take
advantage of the extra minute
so usually when i see someone berserk
okay now
what do you do
it's not going to be easy to block this
uh usually when i see people berserk
then uh you know account or berserk is
in order
oh very very nasty i mean it's always
possible to get out of these positions
but uh
more often than not they just end in
checkmate i guess not maybe not if you
are already but he is down on time very
much and now he's down two pawns i don't
think even alireza can save this one
yeah okay now it's uh
yeah alireza loses this one so it's uh
his first loss of the tournament very
nice
kick in space he okay so this game is
almost all over but there's a lot of
action on the board
uh he won
uh my my previous tournament
no uh a mystery person one he won second
place so i'm sure he's gonna do very
well in this one as well
okay
no no berserking in this one
uh will i make the post kappa blanca
saga maybe at some point i i already
have my next saga prepared and um
uh well
it's hard to say uh how long will it
last
but at some point yeah
yeah a jordan cake cake in space is
jordan
that is uh that is definitely
true
magnus in number 53
okay it's still very early in the
tournament i mean uh it's not even the
first half an hour
so if if if he starts berserking it's
possible that it will
it will go well
what city am i from uh well if you know
uh croatian cities i i'm from krigitsi
ben feingold saga when
uh that should be william hammond thank
thanks for the contribution that should
be uh a netflix original like like
queen's gambit like maybe seven episodes
and that's it on the ben feingold saga
all right very nicely done oh prague is
playing and prague is on a perfect score
so far
uh i can't remember who chess weeb is
even though i'm pretty sure i knew
[Music]
all right so let's see this
yeah title never push f4 yeah
maybe maybe it's f6
alright so no berserking between these
two gentlemen
uh maybe nepo is playing i know he was
about to play but then the side crashed
so i don't know if he rejoined
uh it's dennis borros okay chess weeb is
dennis boris
so so people are saying
[Music]
yeah i know you guys mentioned that
niapo is ge peto but uh i don't know uh
i i haven't seen him now as the
tournament restarted
all right so what's what's happening
here
probably a little bit down on the time
but those pawns are incredibly scary and
i'm um yeah it's uh it's gonna be black
who wins this even though wide's up the
exchange but those pawns are
those pawns are monsters
okay we're gonna we're gonna check out
the dooba game as well of course
all right so the the past pawns are are
simply too strong
no point in uh who is already playing we
always okay so sergey galco versus
alireza would have to check out that one
as well
jigalco also streaming
probably a lot of people are streaming
this event
alright so no berserking in this one
mutual respect i'll i like it or mutual
disrespect could also be
ah one of carlson's losses was banned
ah okay
so it would seem magnus lost to a
cheater
yeah yeah i know you guys keep
mentioning that i can just use the
middle button to open a new tab but i i
just prefer the right left click combo
i don't know if magnus is streaming not
sure
uh i i haven't seen anyone
mentioning it
uh i don't know if duda is playing in
the event
yeah geppetto is nepo
yeah losing to an engine yeah we
expected more from magnus
uh yes i will be covering the rapid
blitz championship uh in great length i
hope but we'll see how much time i will
be having
all right
so nicely done the pawn nicely covers
here and the queen delivers checkmate
all right magnus is back uh back at it
he's currently
in number eight
so let's see
but no berserking for now i think he
wants to get
some some wins in before he starts
berserking
but the one loss was uh
was to a cheater it would seem
yeah juan diaz it was it's a pretty
uh pretty amazing thing yeah i i i i
couldn't imagine of hosting such an
event
hey hikaru in the chat or rather team
hikaru
yeah very glad you guys could join in
okay so what is this
okay so it's a win but uh
it's a win but uh magnus does not get
any points for his win
uh okay magnus versus jordan
let's let's check it out no
berserking uh i i knew who was baba
ramdev but i forgot
yeah i forgot
all right so both players incredibly
fast they only spent 15 seconds so far
okay
yeah some uh sometimes i do drink beer
on streams but only when i have guests
it would be weird if i drank beer alone
although some people do that i just
never thought it was um
never never saw the
the fun in it
okay so he's not giving up anything very
nicely placed knight c3
so the queen rook battery on the c file
isn't all that impressive now
uh we'll see
what magnus can do
here so
applying pressure to that weak d6 pawn
and now the knight will come and help
oh
nicely done okay the queens get traded
off so how will magnus
further pressure the d6 pawn
okay ah the king is coming to help
maybe
b5
that's how he does it yeah it's a double
b pawn so you might as well get to get
rid of it
and now the knight joins the party
uh and that's how he reaches the d6 pawn
incredible okay the bishop can defend it
but then knight d5
uh it's not a lot of fun
okay so that's how you win a pawn in
bullet incredible stuff
do i think magnus is drunk today uh it's
hard to say hard to say i think magnus
only drinks on stream
i think uh he and i share the notion of
of not drinking alone
but you never
know all right so you guys said who was
no it's not alirez is not playing hikaru
hikaru is playing against the biswa
hacker
so hopefully it's not a hacker
no it's a very it's a very tricky
position i don't think uh
i don't think it even looks like
something that
okay so he just blundered the full rook
and hikaru grabs the full point and now
hikaru is in the lead so hikaru uh
alireza
all right let's check out another one
since the game just started let's uh
let's check it out hikaru berserking his
friend not berserking
yeah you can't just have a name like
bishwa hacker and you know play in the
chess tournament
how is magnus number four already well
he uh some would say that he is just
very very good at chess
for those of you who say the quality of
the stream is bad for you uh you should
uh just to remove the quality from auto
and uh choose your own resolution 720 or
you know full hd should work for you
25 currently okay it's still very early
in the tournament i mean we've only uh
we're only in the first half an hour and
it's a two-hour tournament so
uh you know
stamina is also very important here
why was the queen not captured am i
blind or something
yeah that was really weird
isn't this the default leeches board
i'm pretty sure i never changed it i
i've been using this one since the
beginning of time
all right so a nice win for hikaru let's
see uh who is alireza playing
uh all right all right hikaru versus
jessie penco another another top clash
ah this is not default okay
i don't know this is the one i've been
using since forever
yeah you guys are just being weird
alright so let's check out hikaru versus
pink hikaru has a nice pass pawn and e5
already piling up on that c5 pawn
and now
okay the knight
probably going somewhere
maybe to g5 just for fun but no he he's
just gonna double rooks
okay that was a very very very
interesting
but uh he couldn't capture of course and
before the queen was on c7 so that was a
problem
all right we'll see if hikaru gets out
of this one but he did not berserker esi
penko
magnus on third very nice
i should just i should host an evans
gambit tournament all right maybe we
could do like a new year's evans gambit
uh exclusive tournament yeah that might
also be a nice one
and then we we're gonna have all the all
the great uh evans gambit games to show
what is this what is this
madness happening here
is very very close but uh
it doesn't seem to be a move that he can
play
yeah and we have a resignation
all right so hikaru now again reaches
first place
who is alireza playing and who is he
playing all right you guys wanted to
check out magnus but his game is almost
over
uh who do we have
rob from armenia okay but he's already
in the end game
yeah we might as well check out another
hikaru game since uh
he's the only one that's uh that's just
starting out the game
you don't like the board because it
looks dirty
i don't know
uh i will check out uh what are you guys
talking about
uh because i've been using this board
for so many years that i don't even
remember a a different board
i'm sure there's like uh
i'm sure there's like a way you can
check
which board you're using i don't know
even
where you can change that
probably in the settings somewhere yeah
yeah for those of you requesting a
default board i'm not changing the board
this is the board i use and that's final
it's not it's not uh something that we
vote on it's you know your your stream
your board
all right
very nice all right so the g pawn nicely
pinned
and this bishop is going to wreak havoc
here not only can he check he can also
pick up a rook another rook yeah this is
this is game over
oh yeah of course it's different than
the one i use on my youtube videos those
are chess.com boards this is a leeches
board
but i don't think you guys meant that
all right so now it's uh already very
tricky but uh still
he's up a bishop yeah no he resigns okay
he resigns
all right so savored mevco
you guys wanted to check out adobe game
let's check it out
he's playing against international
master chess mood star
and it's a very
very equalished position
dubo is up upon and his opponent's king
side is a bit shattered and he now just
blundered the rook here so that's it
duba wins
there you go all right but that was a
pretty quick one so we could check out
another one all right you guys wanted
another do both game
yeah it's probably so dirty because i
use it too much yeah
good good point
all right he's playing against national
master leonie the uh starshielov
and it's some sort of a okay they both
was berserked so it's going to be a
really quick one
all right so we're going to see trading
of the rooks along the
along the only open file on the board
once the king helps out with the defense
of the of the rook
yeah e5 probably coming
mehmed thanks for the contribution man
try
everyone playing pierce today
yeah everyone is playing pierce uh
uh everyday now it's it's the it's the
new black
kyle sherwood thanks man i know the
board is beautiful it's uh it's why i
use it
it's other people's states that are that
are weird or that's
always the case
all right
oh
nice nice nice nice what is dubose plan
here
okay he did not want to capture that so
he just gave up a rook wow very nice
very nicely done all right what is
happening at the top do we have some
interesting clashes here
uh hikaru vs chess weave who is magnus
playing okay magnus this game is only
just starting so let's check it out he's
playing against international master the
chess experience
i have no idea who that is but we'll see
yep just got blown off the board
yeah it's gonna be like that for
everyone at least a couple of games
thank you mr ethan harvey it was a it
was a pleasure of being a part of uh
just trying to create something like
this
chris houston i i kept it i i still have
it yes
and thank you for the contribution
yeah for those of you who are just
joining in uh pretty much everyone is
playing this tournament there is uh
very few people are not playing it and
even if of course not everyone is
expecting to win but you can get a game
against any of the top player in the
world so you know just that worth uh
makes it worth your while at to join
you miss chucky a lot yeah uh but you
know he he's not gone forever he still
plays
he never got clapped by hikaru
yeah magnus will not defend his title
unless uh unless uh alireza wins the
candidates tournament or so he says and
that's uh you know well within his
rights and uh you know if he's not
motivated to play why would he why would
he spend a month or two of his life uh
preparing for an event that uh
just doesn't motivate him uh you know in
its fullest
yeah he's not the one that has anything
to prove i mean
when will you see the yagamato immortal
game it's coming i promised you it's
coming and you you will see it
so one of the first games i played when
i when i started uh
playing classical tournament chess okay
what is this white has two queens magnus
pushing
pushing those pawns oh
white should be completely winning here
but
those pawns are are incredibly scary
and it's bullet so
probably magnus will win this somehow
but white white might just give up that
bishop for the for the f3 pawn so i
don't know
i don't know how will magnus get out of
this
yeah no it's yeah he has to resign it's
impossible
it's impossible so magnus loses one uh
prague also lost one game
who is hikaru oh hikaru versus duboff
all right let's go
let's do this
oh let's do this yeah
ah rosenbeat hikaru very nice
very nice
yeah uh hikaru built up a very awesome
lead but like i said it's still very
early on in the tournament
and
not as many people are berserking as i
thought they would be
all right so hikaru really going for
dubois trying to beat him uh in his own
game
what can he do how do you defend that
bishop
you really can't yeah okay so he resigns
hikaru finds knight h5 and it's an insta
win very nicely done
very nicely done all right who do we who
do we have next
no games are showing up
okay so here we have one
azaro okay so this one is uh already at
uh at canada mid to end game
and people are saying this is a niche i
do not have this confirmed but uh it
could be
yeah that that uh knight h5 was a real
real really
a beast move
how tall and fisher would have played in
this tournament
well it's uh you know and a question
that can be asked about any player in
any generation in any sport
but if we gave him enough time okay so
he trades down into an end game but
white wants to keep playing
anish of course will try and flag him
because he has a minute and welding is
down to 20 seconds
so
if this is a niche
pairings crashed
oh you guys are kidding me
are you guys are you are you guys
serious that that it crashed
no come on you guys are trolling me
oh it crashed again come on
ah so because it crashed okay
yeah i don't know this is uh
this is unprecedented because they they
said that if the tournament starts uh
starts okay that's that the the
we shouldn't have any more problems
so i actually have no idea what we do
now
but we'll see i mean
okay so he's really trying to
i knew she's trying to flag him but uh
welding is
really wasting no okay so
oh and it's a draw wow
50 move rule i guess so what are you
guys serious that the tournament crashed
i mean games are still being played
but those are probably the ones uh
no
refresh
yeah no games
okay dubo is still playing but uh
ahadubo is playing against gotham
alright so even though the site crashed
uh
even though the site crashed we have a
nice game between duo and gotham gotham
beats duboff
very nicely done
all right
so this yeah i don't know
um
it does seem to be still operational
are you guys sure that it it broke
hikaru still playing his game here
he's trying to okay so he's trying to
flag him that's very very noble
because without flagging what else what
else can we do in such situations okay
so hikar wins this
and is that it
okay but it doesn't appear that anything
crashed it's just that the pairings are
not happening
so let me just check
with with the good team
this is very very strange
[Music]
yeah okay so no games are happening but
we'll see i'm waiting for confirmation
from from the team
yeah another data center fire perhaps
okay so if if it really crashed
if it really crashed then it really
means that this is simply too much
people for for one tournament
all right i'm getting something
ah so okay they're they're saying it
didn't crash it's just uh
[Music]
working slowly so we'll see what happens
so supposedly it it didn't crash
yeah i don't know i don't know what
we're gonna do on this one
yeah the hamster stop it stopped working
again
are there no games happening let me just
check
yeah the servers simply cannot uh cannot
withstand so much chess
i you got a game after waiting five
minutes
yeah there are no games happening here
wow
okay so uh
obviously there there are some games
here is a game happening
but maybe that's that's one that that
lasted before
yeah i don't think we can stop the timer
uh we'll see we'll see if they can fix
it somehow
uh maybe they can just uh
continue the tournament and add
additional time for for the time lost i
don't know
yeah the only winner here is chess.com
yeah
no doubt
yeah thanks for the contribution
contribution maxim nietzsche but uh
stop the count
yeah i don't know uh what we're gonna do
now you i we can't really restart the
tournament because it's uh already going
on for more than an hour
uh and i don't think the the players
would would be happy about that so maybe
they can fix it somehow
i'm sure they have some sort of a
fail-safe fail-safe mechanism for
situations like this
yeah kick the bottom half of the field
yeah they didn't pay their power bill
yeah and that's why why that's why it's
important for you guys to always support
leeches financially so they can afford a
better better servers
that's probably how it works
hikaru just doesn't care
no no it was uh it was always uh
minimum minimum 1800 i believe
yeah it's not it's not a squid game
uh i don't think they implemented the
pause timer
for for the tournament function
yeah i thought about making it titled
only but that's one of the reasons why i
made this tournament is so you guys uh
can get a chance to play against some of
these uh you know world-class players
even even if it's just for a couple of
first rounds uh you know yeah you know
you guys will maybe maybe get a game
against hikaru or or alireza or magnus
and uh
i thought it was uh it was worth it with
you know without just making it a titled
event
[Music]
yeah okay so currently it is you have to
be at least 1800 to place so i guess
leeches had to implement this in order
to
prevent too much
too much players but
okay that's that's not over overdoing it
thanks big moody
thank you i i try
ah you were you were entered with less
than 1800 yeah i guess they're
i guess they're now trying to
reduce the number of players by limiting
it with rating
so we'll see
i'm still not getting anything uh
well worst case scenario they upgrade
their servers at some point and we
repeat the tournament
maybe maybe we do an actual christmas
one
uh because uh this is a as far as i know
an unprecedented scenario
yeah gotham gotham beat dubo we managed
to see the end of the game
er at least yazarov won 20 rating points
so it it wasn't for nothing
[Music]
yeah world blitz and rapid championship
is uh happening
from 25th to 30th of december so those
dates are out of the question but maybe
31st
gotham dancing like a tick tock girl
after that win yeah who wouldn't after
after beating him
no but they they really uh maybe should
add a feature of stopping the clock
unless everything runs perfectly smooth
no i didn't see hikaru lose to eric
but i'm pretty sure we could
see the game
uh while we're waiting so this is hikaru
versus eric eric with white
alright so let's just see what happened
supposedly it was a pretty pretty crazy
one
okay so just gets traded off and now
this uh funky
queen move
all right
check okay
now eric blunders completely
but
okay
oh that's what he missed rook f1 and now
he can't defend the rook
yeah okay
okay that's how he won
very nice so even even hikaru can
blunder like this okay
queen queen captures on g3 why not grab
a pawn
but it doesn't seem like it'll be
it'll be work it'll be working
does hikaru win the tournament if the
technical glitch is not resolved no i
don't think he does because we weren't
even at the half half mark of the
tournament
and we don't have uh
yeah we don't we don't have a
not even a fail-safe mechanism but also
we don't have uh what happens in case
like
you know the the server runs down
is the issue resolved uh nope i i still
am not receiving anything from leeches
uh
probably working on it so i don't know
your your guess is really as good as
mine how this can be resolved but uh
i'm i i only got everyone together i i
have no uh no way of helping them
uh you know in any way
yeah okay we could we could uh
we could make uh you have to be rated at
least 2 000 to join but like i said that
that's what i wanted to avoid
[Music]
between hikaru and tikkun the guy who
won the first arena when the leeches
crashed yeah
all right so
all right let's see
okay so magnus had only one loss here
but yeah that's obviously the one where
no no that's not the one
he played against jordan
okay this was the last game so if the
time ran out probably he
okay so something happened
time is no longer ticking
okay so
the tournament is complete
although the tournament is complete
although we will not be ending it
right now
still waiting uh
for leeches to get back at me
you were number 10 at some moment
uh the tournament isn't working because
they had to
rest they will probably i don't know
i don't know if it's even possible to
resume it now maybe they can somehow
resume it and restart it at the point
where it got cut off if such a thing is
possible i don't know
yeah of course i'm i'm pretty sure there
is a way where you could resume it uh
where it's close but not the same but
since this is a prized event you can't
you can't just you know do whatever you
like
yeah next time only titles players yeah
says the the berserk button was not
working for him that's why he got down
[Music]
that is that is very strange
um okay so still waiting to hear
yeah they are working on it
he says he was pressing berserk but it
simply wasn't working
yeah that is that is strange
you have to double click the berserk
button no i i don't think that's the
case
double click seriously you have to
double click
wow okay
let me just transfer that
[Music]
uh okay i haven't played a
tournament bullet or hyper bullet in
quite some time now but i'm pretty sure
you didn't have to double click it or
maybe you did
it's pretty weird
yeah i i agree the fun of of the these
tournaments is that everyone can play
but
seems like everyone is is simply too
much people
too many people
ah single click works okay so i don't
know i mean i i don't remember
it was uh a few months since i last
played uh
a tournament where i where i actually
used berserk
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay the the first crash happened
during the first minute so that's
perfectly fine
uh they said that something like this
could happen but the second one now
happened after an hour of the tournament
actually running
uh
yeah so if the tournament started well
it probably should have been like half
an hour to the end of the tournament now
[Music]
[Music]
nope uh st okay i'm getting some
response
oh okay
uh
yeah no guys i think uh
i think that's it for today
uh because leeches says that the server
is dead for today uh so that the
tournament will not be continuing
so unfortunately that seems to be it for
the tournament uh we're gonna see what
what we do from here
uh because uh well it's uh just very
unexpected that something like this
would happen
uh but uh yeah
will see we'll see what happens
uh so so sorry to everyone i i didn't
think that something uh well like this
was possible
uh even though it i mean it's it's not
up to me but uh
yeah i just thought that everything can
be fixed but obviously it can't
so we'll see
uh and sorry yeah to all the players who
came so many players but uh
okay you you wasted an hour joining this
and maybe okay missed some other events
that you could have
could have played but um
yeah as they say it's dead for today
uh so well no i i will have to check
whether we whether we continue with
something like uh like another event or
yeah we'll probably have to transfer it
[Music]
yeah we will pro uh
yeah okay
there will be a solution of some sort
but uh probably not uh not today no
definitely not today
uh so yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna head over
and discuss it with them but it seems
that this is it for this event so uh
that's it guys i will i will inform you
what we decide and how how this will
play out
all right
uh
yeah uh that's it guys uh thank you for
joining in but it seems that uh we have
to end the stream now and i will inform
everyone of course on twitter and other
social media
uh to uh
uh to to what we've decided
all right uh see you very soon guys